hey guys this is andrew from
trainsenses.com so i'm a professional
trader and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank in hong kong for the past
six years
and i just started to make some youtube
videos where i share with you guys all
my experience
and i try to show you guys the different
techniques used by pro traders
so if you want to understand how we work
and how we actually make money on the
markets you are in the right place
so today i want to talk about clvs and
amc
which are two potential targets of the
game stoppers
let's get into it
[Music]
alright so let's start with amc
which is a very hot stock uh where we
had a lot of a lot of
volume yesterday so this is one of the
target chosen by
the gamestopers so the guys that are on
reddit the guys that are on a wall
street bet
that discuss what stock to buy
especially if the stock is very weak
and when you have a lot of short
interest all right so on
amc you have around 30 40 of uh short
interest so it's a nice target
you can see the earnings are really bad
they're losing 4 billion all right in
one quarter
so this is a stock that is very in a
very bad situation
and still it went really
up in the past week 1 000
guys all right so let's do a bit of
technical analysis because once again
technical analysis
is the analysis of the flows and it's
the best situation to actually
use the good thing of technical analysis
and
forget about the fundamentals all right
so here
very basic guys we have a trend we have
a trend
we have a resistance we have a
resistance we have a breakout
and you can see that there is plenty of
room gamestop
is for example way too extended for me
to enter in this trade
but here let me put this in orange
here we have a nice target that we can
reach all right it's the maximum level
of the of the
of the stock that was in 217 we are not
there yet so gamestop for example is
already in this kind of levels
and here we just opened at this level
and where did we close guys
are we closed here all right but this
actually
is a very nice level to buy if you want
to participate in this financial
revolutions
and be part of the battle that is
starting between small money investors
and big money investors like hedge fund
if you want to put down some
some hedge funds it's up to you guys but
this is a stock
that i would see going higher especially
if people continue to buy it
everywhere in the world and if people
talk about it which i'm doing here
so technically i would buy it here put a
stop loss just below
so i would put a stop loss around eight
all right i would buy it around 11
if you have a re-test for example here
in this area
so you have around 30 potential loss
but you can make much more than this you
can make around 200
so guys this is a different way of
trading i'm not used to it but you can
apply the same method if your risk
reward is above three
why not all right why not but be careful
guys once again
because one day things just might go
wrong
and everything that is overvalued might
actually come back to normal levels if
hedge funds uh use their power and
associate together just as
like the game stoppers are doing i don't
know what's gonna happen but it's
probably gonna be
bloody and not good for the long
investors
so i'm quite bullish above 10
on amc next one clvs
same thing i checked the earnings
beautiful downtrend so it's a target and
the short interest
i didn't put it here but it's a bit
lower it's around
20 i think i would need to check again i
can
send you this in the comments later but
uh we have a nice
short interest a lot of hedge funds are
short and once again if they need to buy
back the position
they're gonna create a short squeeze
here we didn't have it yet
guys so this is to me the best candidate
because we have this download sloping
trendline that has been broken
has it been retested not retested yet
the moving averages are just here
so guys you can buy it around seven put
a stop loss
uh ten percent lower once around six ten
fifteen percent lower and
benefit from a very large move up guys
if this
awakes if we have the same stuff that
happens you can have 1 000
so to to me clds is a very nice
candidate but careful guys this is a
medical firm
you never know what kind of news gonna
happen maybe they're gonna find
something that is not working anymore in
the way they were doing things i don't
know
so careful with some with this medical
stocks but
technically we have a nice breakout not
retested yet
so i would uh i would go there again
with a stop loss guys
don't get wiped out don't lose
everything but here you have
a very uh nice potential gain
that you can lock if you enter your
position here
and i would take a target so this would
be my last target and i would maybe
sell half already here
and then one quarter here and one
quarter here so
you see you enter your position here you
take fifty percent here so it's already
making
sixty percent and then you go to the
next one
three three hundred percent and the next
one one thousand percent
and once again this uh support level
that was resistance is gonna work quite
well i think in the next week two weeks
so six seven is a nice level to buy all
right guys that's it for me i hope
this video was helpful for you to
understand how we can use technical
analysis
even on those penny stocks where you
have those short squeeze that are
happening right now
because of the massive short position
held by hedge funds
and if you did please don't forget to
hit the like
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys